rent is high apartment inventory low we
have new data on the housing crisis what
local renters should know about trends
to come plus tips for negotiating your
rent
i don't think that this is really
sustainable in the long run these rent
prices being up so high brian carberry
is with rent.com the site says since
january apartment rental prices are up
about three to four percent for one and
two bedrooms nationwide for the las
vegas area prices for one bedroom
actually rents relatively flat a little
bit down uh four percent the two
bedrooms up 14
last summer rent went up across the
country 26 percent in hot markets like
austin texas people are paying 80
percent more than last year paying on
average a thousand dollars more now than
they were at this time last year
carberry believes prices will keep
increasing but at a slower pace
regardless of where you live everyone
could use a little help negotiating
their rent but is there room for that
right now a lot of landlords really are
not willing to negotiate because the
demand is so high in the competition is
so fierce here are a few things to try
when signing a new lease or renewing
simply ask if there is wiggle room in
the price you have a little bit more
going in your favor if you are looking
to renew your lease and the landlord
knows you if you're moving into a new
home see if you can sign a longer lease
to lock in the monthly price
if you live in an urban community with a
parking space sometimes that can be
negotiated see if you can negotiate that
parking back parking is one of the prime
amenities that people are looking for
especially families who may have
multiple drivers
if you can give that back to a landlord
they may be willing to cut a little bit
of slack for you and cut a little bit
off your rent price because then they
can take that spot and market it to
someone else and get that money from
another renter
if you would like to look at all the
rental trends here in southern nevada
you can find the report on our website
at 8newsnow.com